hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Emmanuel Kant in the proliga to any
future metaphysics in the first part of
the transcendental question which is
concerned with how how pure mathematics
is possible is going to spend a lot more
time talking about examples from and
inferences that we can draw about
geometry that he is going to talk about
arithmetic or mechanics or any of that
and you might say why is that the case
well Kant seems to think that it's
really important to focus on space as
one of the forms of
intuition uh it is also itself an AR
priori intuition and we find that he
tells us that pure mathematics which is
synthetic cognition uh priori so it's
it's cognition
Arness that um puts you know additional
things together it's not merely analytic
and it is a priori so it has necessity
aidic universality to it he says it's
possible only by referring to no other
objects and objects there is not objecta
but
gag uh things that we actually take as
objects but those of the senses uh zinit
right the multiple forms of
sensibility that we have and this kind
of goes
against you know a lot of theories of
mathematics that view mathematics as
something kind of special it deals with
an ideal Realm of numbers and then you
know when it comes to Geometry we have
to figure out okay well how does
geometry connect up to what we call
often call the real world we we call the
world of appearances or
phenomena or representations right the
world in which we do experience time and
space and things in them so he tells us
that there is an AR priori pure
intuition at the basis of empirical
intuition what is that well you know
we've talked about this elsewhere the
forms of intuition namely time and space
which are there before we even have
things in time or space and he tells us
that you know this intuition doesn't
represent things as they are in
themselves but as they have to be for us
and so he says my intuition can contains
nothing but the form of
sensibility um which is in in me as a
subject precedes all the actual
Impressions through which I'm affected
by objects okay so so far so good now
geometry tells us is based on the pure
intuition of space not time arithmetic
is is based on time and then we have
this other thing pure mechanics which we
don't need to worry about because he
only uses a few examples of this
although one of them shows up in the
many examples that he uses for geometry
and so he tells
us this is in section 12 in order to add
something by way of illustration and
Confirmation we need only watch the
ordinary and unavoidably necessary
procedure of geometers people who are
engaging in Geometry whether they're
teachers or researchers or students who
are learning it and he says all proofs
of the complete congruence of two given
figures so if you've taken a geometry
class you know that congruence is a very
important idea and what does it mean it
means essentially that one is
exchangeable for the other when it comes
to figures and how do you know this you
can
superimpose one onto the other and you
don't get any surplus any place where
one doesn't
overlap with the other this means that
you can substitute one for the other and
Kant is going to say this is a synthetic
proposition okay so a proposition that's
teaching us something new resting on
immediate intuition okay so far so good
immediate intuition you're looking at
stuff aha but it's
not intuition that is empirical of our
experience he says this is uh an
intuition which is AR priori pure and AR
priori
otherwise we wouldn't have it being
apodictically certain certain in every
case we could say well we've done these
tests a lot with taking figures and
imposing them on each other and it looks
like in the you know all of the cases
we've seen so far no no that doesn't get
you universality that doesn't get you
necessity that has what he calls
empirical certainty only in that case it
could only be said it is always found to
be so so and holds good as far as far as
our perception reaches and K says well
that's not what geometry is actually
promising or claiming to us geometry
saying hey if you do things like proofs
in Geometry you get knowledge you can
take as absolutely certain right so
that's an interesting discussion there
and then he gives you a whole bunch of
other examples now some of these may be
more controversial than others K claims
space can have only three dimensions now
he might be wrong about that there's
other alternative models of space that
say that there are more but anyways he's
he's going to say complete space has
three dimensions and that space in
general cannot have more is based on
what based on the
proposition that no more than three
lines can intersect a point at right
angles so you know visualize this to
yourself you have you know a single line
going through a point you've got one
dimension you got another line bisecting
it at a right angle 90° Angle now you've
actually got the XY plane and now you do
a third one going through and now we
have a third dimension and can you put
any more in no because you're not going
to get any more right angles at least in
Geometry as we typically think of it and
as we
experience the world so Kant is saying
you can't just sit in your you know
let's use that old locution Ivory Tower
or armchair and you know think to
yourself how many dimensions should I
give to space you actually have to like
think about how things come together uh
but you're you're doing so not by
carrying out some sort of empirical
experiment you are doing this in your
mind and thinking about about the
conditions for the possibility of space
as we know it and he says this
proposition cannot be shown from
Concepts but rests immediately on
intuition and so you might say oh it
rests on intuition we do something
empirical with this nope once again this
is pure intuition a priori because it's
apodictically certain so it's it's the
intuition of space itself as a form for
empirical intuition he also talks about
another example the infinite
continuation of a line you never
actually do see an infinite line in the
space that we inhabit right because it's
infinite the fact that it doesn't end
would mean you you can't see that
endlessness can you or he says uh a
series of changes for example Spaces
traversed by motion that these are
infinitely continued presupposes a
representation of
forell right of now notice what he says
space and time so here we're dealing
with not just geometry but also pure
mechanics at least with the
changes the line okay that could be pure
geometry but now it's no longer a pure
intuition of space as the form of
empirical intuition it is a let's say
Fuller intuition at its basis of both
space and time coming together in a
certain way that turns out to be the
same in in every case and for every
rational being so geometry is
illustrating by unpacking these examples
that we really are working with
something that is the form of
sensibility for us and then he says you
know those who cannot rid themselves of
the notion that space and time are
actual qualities inherent in things
themselves inherent in the nature of the
universe may exercise their Acumen on
the following Paradox and he's actually
going to give three different examples
of this
Paradox first one is a little bit hard
to visualize he talks about spherical
triangles that is triangles that are
inscribed within a sphere so he says um
here we go if two things are quite equal
in all respects as much as can be
ascertained by all means possible
quantitatively and qualitatively it must
follow that the one in all cases and
under all circumstances must be able to
replace the other and the substitution
would not occasion the least
recognizable difference so this is the
congruence that we're talking about
earlier but we have with sided we could
call them fig figures in congruence
between them so he says this is true of
plain figures in Geometry but some
spherical
figures exhibit not withstanding a
complete internal agreement a difference
in their external relation that the one
figure cannot be put in the place of the
other so they're not
congruent so two spherical triangles on
opposite hemispheres which have an arc
of the Equator as their common base may
be quite equal
as regards their sides and angles um but
the one cannot be put in the place of
the other on the opposite hemisphere so
you've got a sphere and you could take
these triangles and you could actually
like you know flip one around and if
they're just an empty space by itself
they're congruent but you can't do that
on the place in the sphere because it's
not going to fit and so what is we're
going to see what this reveals to us in
just a second he's got another great
example of your two hands he says you
don't have to necessarily do geometry
you can look at your everyday
experience what can be more similar in
every respect in every part more alike
to my hand and my
ear then not the other hand but their
image in a mirror right because you
could say well you know this hand over
here has got different uh proportions
than this one you know this is my
dominant hand I actually semi amidex so
my dominant hand isn't that much more
dominant but some people have big right
hands and smaller left hands are vice
versa right not that mirror image so you
got this hand and then you've got it
flipped around in a mirror or we might
use an you know a a selfie or we might
use whatever else we want to to reverse
it so he
says if this is a right hand then in the
mirror it's a left hand right and the
image or reflection of the right ear is
a left one and these can never serve as
a substitute for the other there are no
internal differences which our
understanding could determine by
thinking alone but the differences are
internal as the senses sensibility
teaches us for notwithstanding their
complete equality and similarity how do
you know they they're not the same the
left hand cannot be enclosed in the same
bound as the right one they're not
congruent and you know what's a very
common way of understanding this you
can't use your left glove on your right
hand right whereas you could perhaps
with uh some other body parts similarly
if you had like a nice container for
your ear you can't uh simply put the
left one in the the right one or on the
right one and so he says um there's one
other one that we could consider he
mentions this just in passing opposing
winding helixes so a helix is a
spiraling figure that isn't just a
spiral in one dimension but in or in two
Dimensions rather but in three
dimensions right so think of the DNA
Helix right you can have a helix and
it's got a certain kind of spin to it we
could say well you can flip it around
and it's not the same Helix anymore how
do you know that these aren't completely
interchangeable with each other so Kant
says these objects are not pure are not
representations forell of things as they
are in themselves and as some pure
understanding would cognize them they're
sensuous intuitions that is appearances
a shinan whose possibility rests on the
relation of certain things unknown in
themselves to something else namely to
our sensibility so he says space is the
form of the external intuition of this
sensibility and this is a a really
important thing he's going to tell us
right
spaces that we can look at see sense
spaces um or the internal determination
of any space is only possible by the
determination of its external relation
to the the whole the entirety of space
so even though we never take in the
entirety of space we are you could say
placing the things that we sense as
representations within that total space
now that's an interesting observation to
make he says in other words by its
relation to external sense the part is
Possible only through the whole which is
never the case with things in themselves
as object of the mirror understanding
but can be the case with appearances so
all the empirical representations or
appearances that we are taking in
through our senses are arranged in the
entirety of space which we intu it a
priori as a whole but as the form of
sensibility now there's a very
important implication of this that Kant
is going to draw out in remark
one so
he says
um pure mathematics especially pure
geometry can only have objective reality
on condition it refers merely to objects
of sense but the principle holds good
that our sense representation is not a
representation of things in themselves
but the way they appear to to us so it
follows that the propositions of
geometry expressing geometry as a
science are not creations of a Are Not
Mere cre creations of our poetic
imagination which could not be referred
to Assurance with actual objects so
geometry is not a kind of madeup Ideal
discipline nothing in in reality really
fits geometry as a matter of fact it's
the other way around for for Kant he
goes on and he says
that the propositions of geometry are
necessarily valid of space and
consequently of all that may be found in
space that means everything that we
grasp through our senses in space as
representations or appearances is
handled by geometry so he says um
because space is nothing but the form of
external appearances and it is this form
alone in which objects of sense can be
given to us so the appearances can never
contain anything but what geometry
prescribes es to them this means that
geometry is yielding us knowledge a
priori of
everything potentially that could be
experienced By Us in space and perhaps
you know with certain extensions in time
as well so this which may be contestable
is a very
important point that Kant is making here
about the nature of geometry itself why
geometry works the way it does why it
has as he calls it its apodictic
certainty or
necessity